hello freak bitches how much material do
you think like I would say if you're
gonna become a big-name stand-up
comedian you're gonna have to put out a
bunch of specials right so if you put
out how many specials can you do on your
life
before you have to start talking about
other shit probably four five four five
specials you know a lot of stuff that I
remember like it was so at the time like
I can laugh at it now but back then it
was pain so I didn't get on drugs like
my sister did I didn't do my brother
didn't got on drugs to deal with
bullshit that we was going through I
just stayed you know sober and thought
these motherfucker was crazy
so to get rid of the pain I just kept
putting it in the back of my head I
didn't want to remember it so when I
became a comic all of this shit started
rushing through my brain and I had the
excellent sister bitches this world I
just asked my sister other day my
granddaddy ran a bootleg house so in
this bootleg house I had a retarded
uncle named uncle Cecil that was
crippled but my granddaddy would buy him
pussy on Friday but me and my sister
would have to go in there with the
prostitute and hold his legs back until
he get his dick in before we could go
outside and play so I called her up and
I said is this shit real gonna hold his
legs back cuz he's with cripple you know
how when they need so he couldn't he
couldn't get it in until we moved his
fucking legs back I remember what I was
like areum probably eight I was like
okay sister put it in his fucking smile
because he will retard ease I know it's
so fucking up and I asked my brother I
was like do y'all remember this shit I'm
going crazy and I don't like call my
brother last week and I said my mama
used to had this theory she said when it
when it rains and the sun is shining the
devil was beating his wife you ever
heard a us and she said we were rain and
the lightning and the sunshine he called
the beast cheese though she's my mom's
like you should be the bitch cuz she
don't believe in God talking about you
crazy bitch
I used to think they stole me Joe nobody
could be before to this fucking crazy I
am being distracted by how much I have
to urinate oh the other day I was
talking about
I'm glad guys just started man I know
but I was not prepared I had wine I
drank a whole one of these good yeah
stay out and I had a bunch of coffee
this morning too but I was thinking
yesterday this is related how much would
you weigh if you never went to the
bathroom
you'd be dead how quickly it wouldn't
take long what if we had evolved to just
not ever have to like a baby after just
a month would be bigger than the biggest
human ever don't you think I need to do
the math well it depends on would you
need to consume like if your body was so
efficient that you no longer needed your
name like we kind of assumed that your
body would need to urinate but why if
your body needs water to stay alive like
what is why are we assuming that it has
to well it has to get rid of some waste
that it doesn't want anymore
well why could could we just turn that
into more hair instead but why does it
have to get rid of waste like isn't it
possible that we can become so efficient
that we no longer need to get rid of
waste and we can just sort of exist by
breathing right here all right
completely just like self yeah we
running to get to a certain size and
once we get to a certain size we just
you know whatever you evaporate off by
walking around like that you have to
take back in right I guess you know yeah
cuz they they have you know robots that
that just dissipate heat and they don't
ever make a waste product your laptop
doesn't create as much waste as a human
but it's also not nearly as like complex
right but in some ways it's more complex
they've been able to make machines that
can poop you put food in and then it's
got bacteria in different pumps and
reservoirs inside and it creates
something that resembles completely and
smells just like a human dump whoa yeah
the first one I saw was done as a piece
of art as artwork like an artist created
this machine that could poop just like a
human and now they do it they call it a
robo gut inside
like a medical thing because when people
have GI problems a poop transplant is
commonly used reintroduce the healthy
bacteria and taking poop from someone
else and giving it to the sick person
shoving it up there is kind of like you
know there's a lot of possibilities for
rejection infection stuff like that I
guess but the Robo gut can make just
perfectly clean poop just look the kind
that you want whoa yeah
because some artificial poop put up
inside of you to fix any imbalances that
you have in your gut flora that's fast
and that crazy you have like a poop farm
of robot intestine right that are just
and what do you feed them
yeah do you feel like do burger runs for
the Robo gets the Mindy it's gonna
totally argue it's got to be totally
organic it's gotta probably it's
probably just like a paste or a liquid
it's like baby food you wouldn't have to
taste good the robots not gonna complain
you know fuck that robot just eat it
bitch yeah well you mean when jay-z went
to Cuba oh my god and everyone the media
was like oh look it does he know that
that fucking che hated black people
you're like what are you talking about
like what is going on it was the
weirdest in Che Guevara died like 1964
something weird Che Guevara died and he
also went over there Golan fought like
the revolution in Africa so it's like I
don't know if that's really true but
it's just so crazy he was the perfect
guy though beyond t-shirt he just looked
like such a great revolutionary I know
people that wore a Che Guevara t-shirt
that didn't know jack shit about
remember there was that wave of Che
Guevara support that happened like like
a decade ago right nobody was really
what they're talking about like you can
look cool I have with a Che Guevara
t-shirt on people had Che Guevara
tattoos and it's like why what about Che
right fucking and he would have hated it
I mean like the fact that he's become
this commercial figure it'd have been
like he would have fucking hated that
you know it's just funny that he's
become this icon of like capital well
it's a perfect example of these like
surface enquiries like people just had
no no like looking into it at all no
trying to understand who he was or no
like deeply about who he was yeah this
is like a baby
even though